running as we a very sexy sport prove
that is is mr. Tom Hanks because I
believe your wife or one of her favorite
scenes is you running Oh oh dear that
running wave scene yes every interview
will be about Forrest Gump at some point
because you'll be asking questions about
st. going for the rest of you there
there is I was I had done not the
workouts tree but I had worked out quite
a bit and it was all about running and I
must say that my my buttocks as Forrest
would say whereas furnace tend hams they
they were just the I've seen the movie
and I've seen it and every now and again
if it comes by on on the cable my wife
will say let just leave it here honey I
just see that one scene where you're
running away from them
[Applause]
I even think it's a beautiful thing to
behold another link between moe and Tom
because the last time you were on you
remember the those memes people would do
the moe fire of running away some things
so Moe fire running away from a bear a
bull run no power in the sound of music
[Music]
there is one of Mo Farah running away
from Forrest Gump
[Laughter]
it's amazing what it does it says
where'd you go for a run you go to all
that trouble to becoming a famous runner
and they're still calling you another
name ticket folks could you do
everything just cos Moe's here he's the
greatest runner in the world could you
do the the line from Forrest Gump where
he suddenly discovers how much he likes
running I would happy to do it but you
must show the lady with a cute card
because otherwise people will think that
I've actually memorized this is for you
moe this is for you mom and now you
wouldn't believe me if I told you but I
could run like the wind blows from that
day on if I was going somewhere I was
running
to hit
[Music]
you